in respect of many of these
technological projects of immortality
what survives is not the person who once
lived in kurt wiles version as I
understand it what is proposed is that
elements of the conscious mind of the
conscious self of the people concerned
are somehow programmed computed and then
projected into cyberspace where that
self-aware mind can create a variety of
bodies for itself in a virtual
environment so rather than having the
one frail aging vulnerable body that we
each of us have to start with people can
have a whole variety of different bodies
different genders when they get bored
with them or want to change them for
other reasons they can have as many as
they want my objection is that what
would serve I would not be the person
because first of all it would only be
the parts of the person which are
conscious and can be programmed and my
view is that the larger part of each of
us and a large part of where our
creativity in it in our lives comes from
both artistic and intellectual
creativity it's not conscious it's in
its it's in part of ourselves which is
not accessible to conscious awareness so
if my conscious life my conscious
intellectual life is somehow encoded or
encrypted and then projected into a
virtual afterlife what there will be out
there will be a sort of thinned out
cartoon of the person that's endowed
image of the whole person I once was
and I'm not interested in that kind of
immortality I wouldn't accept it if I
offered offered it I might very well
accept an extension of long get of
healthy longevity of the kind that
Aubrey de Grey talks about we are
already living longer and healthier than
many previous human generations did I
see nothing inherently wrong with that
but indefinite longevity is not
immortality it's not the kind of radical
freedom from bodily frailty that
futurist such as Kurt Weill want